the Joe Rogan experience yeah I mean
maybe got better as time went on I
didn't see it know who I really like too
was the his assistant that guy that
helped him out that would do anything
for him yeah I killed Rachel Brosnahan
yeah when you pushed in front of a
trench no you kidding no no that was him
that was Kevin Spacey kills basic girl
for the Train right and that was a guy
who went back killed a hooker right now
that hooker went on to be the marvelous
mrs. Mazal that's right Rachel Rachel
Brosnahan that's right yeah yeah that's
right she's dumb she's married oh it's
great in that Mazal show yes that is a
good [ __ ] show you know Amazon's
doing comedy specials now are they did
Jim Jim Gaffigan oh it did Russell
Peters and they're doing some other ones
well I'll do one with them I'll do one
over there Amazon I'll do one I like it
yeah it's cool breaking the mold in the
Netflix mold
everybody has Amazon Prime dude
everybody does but now there are some
old foods when you go to hold it once
you get a good discount on [ __ ]
that's wild I was like but she was like
do you have your app you scan your
[ __ ] out nice get yourself a little
bit of little monkey legs what do you
want
thank you all for you some bags of
spinach once you check out two dollars
off we Amazon person nice yeah um Amazon
yeah and they're the [ __ ] world man
content they're doing you by I'm gonna
wear weird company you buy stuff with
one click you can watch TV shows to make
a TV show so you could go buy your
groceries when are they gonna mow open
up their town Town town where is it
where's it go Buffalo they need it they
feel in Buffalo like please mmm would
you go to Amazon town would you live
there no you'd be a mess
Jamie would you live inside a lot of
brown boxes everywhere we recycle and
everything there changed every the way
like grocery stores have to work now
because they have that two-hour delivery
like you have to deliver your grocery
store it's [ __ ] awesome Pete I know
but they do that with Whole Foods to
write this Whole Foods deliver yes yes
we will most grocers we will reach a
point now when we don't go into grocery
stores that's crazy
they'll deliver dude was a kid no
grocery stores delivered do you remember
never I've never heard of that deliver
delivery no that didn't exist when did
that start they do have the store to
worry you walk in and just it feels like
you're stealing I usually just leave and
they charge your account oh my god you
don't know York they tested it out
people just walk in and you have the app
in your phone so when you walk out it
registers what you have with you whoa
okay that's [ __ ] insane living in the
future bro Dawg you will know there will
be a point when we don't ever go to
those things someone just will give it
you get an order every week how long
will it be before they can replicate
food and all you have to do is like put
the bare ingredients and amino acids and
[ __ ] into some VAT and then you print up
anything you want right ends up 3d print
a steak 3d printed Apple 3d print I'm
hungry for baked potato pizza yeah
really really print it comes out yeah
but you know what what it's not gonna
taste good you know because food has
love and that [ __ ] people say that oh
you these new cars Moon's no soul okay
no the food is different nutritionists
ever you can ever take you can't take
you can you know it's just elements just
little things that they figure out how
to [ __ ] move around wiggle I don't
know something about there being so
nanjing perfect comes out a nice like
toast the crossed your [ __ ] computer
[Applause]